today the idea behind arranging this
webinar was more to have an interactive
discussion about this program what the
outcomes could be and who all can be a
part of this program what are the
different specialization tracks that you
can work on in this program and also
answer other questions right so let's
get started but before I start
discussing about these specialization
tracks I really want to know the
background of the participants who have
joined us today so what is your
background are you all uh students
graduate students or postgraduate
students or are you researchers please
let me know in the chat box and if
you're a student then you're from which
stream is it biotechnology
bioinformatics biochemistry microbiology
or also we have seen interest by medical
students are you a medical student I see
some responses in the chat let's see
okay we have people from computer
science background as well that is nice
PhD in mental health that's interesting
post graduate and bioinformatics so we
have people from different fields today
who have joined the session it's good to
see we have a student in BSE
Neuroscience as well same as request
postgraduate and biochemistry
all right this is good to know about all
of you uh and you all come from
different fields and my second question
to you would be what is your research
and trust and have you do you have a
specific research in trust because of
which you have joined today's webinar
you want to work on a project
your research interests could be a
specialization track maybe that is what
you can tell me in the chat box uh you
want to work with you the neurosciences
in the neurosciences field or you want
to work with infectious diseases or in
the field of oncology
genomics yeah you can also tell me about
different data types that you would like
to work with genomics transcriptomics
metagenomics or epigenomics
all right and many of you who are
students here from Bachelors uh
background VSC students or btech
students and sometimes also it happens
with Master students that they are not
sure uh in which research field they
would like to uh carry out their
research project or simply their
dissertation to submit in their college
that happens and it and it is normal it
is common that it happens and uh this
today this session is to tell you about
the different fields that you can
explore and work on a research project
and if you're a student who does not
have a research interest at all it's all
right we are here to help you out figure
out one and then work with that
particular research topic and Excel as
rotated all right so without Much Ado
let's now uh discuss about some of
theories sources that you can leverage
to either figure out a research interest
or if you have a research interest
already then how can you leverage these
resources to learn about a specific type
of data analysis that you are interested
to learn about and work on your research
project so I will take this step by step
first of all I want you all to have this
link handy that is the link to the
ormythogic learn portal and on this
portal I'll quickly show you some of the
resources that you can leverage and who
will leverage as a part of this research
fellowship program
so uh the research fellowship program
could either be of three months or six
months and in the beginning of this
program we take you through a training
process because obviously if you want to
work with a specific type of data be it
transcriptomic or metagenomic or genomic
or epigenomic it's important for you to
learn about the to get the concepts
clear the concepts cleared about the
specific field maybe and also to learn
about Venus algorithms I'll say or tools
that could be used to analyze that
specific type of data all right and this
training period is from a month to two
months depending on the duration for
which you enroll now this is the courses
tab on the portal where you have all of
these courses listed out I won't be
going in too much depth of the courses
right now but I'll just give you an
overview of what do we have here that
you can learn from so we have mentioned
about different types of omics data that
is one thing I'll just open up one
specific coursework and show you the
different components that we have put
together in each of these courses so we
have three different components that we
have put together the first component is
where we have explained the concepts
related to that specific field so we
have transptonics one coursework where
we are trying to explain what is
transcriptomics first of all what are
the different types of sequencing
techniques how do you get this data and
then how do you process this data and
before processing this data how do you
extract the data from Maybe be public
repositories or if you're a researcher
who is generating this data in your lab
it could be a case that you're a
biotechnologist and you are generating
this data in your lab but you want to
learn how to analyze this data all right
so we begin from the very basic level
different sequencing types then what
type of data format you need to have and
then how you run the pipeline now when
you run the pipeline what are the
biggest algorithms involved in running
these pipelines and I've been talking
about pipelines and algorithms I'll just
show you briefly what this pipeline is
all about what these algorithms are all
about and when you run an algorithm you
need to specify some parameters what are
these and what bases you have to specify
them all of this is mentioned in these
lessons this will help you and guide you
run a pipeline and get the the required
results now when you have your results
in hand it's very important for you to
understand how do you interpret
biological insights from your results so
again all of it is mentioned here in the
coursework now these are simple learn
lessons that will guide you through the
conceptual part and will also give you
some guidelines on how do you run the
pipeline and then how do you interpret
your results
now there are people who want to learn
our coding or maybe use our coding or
use Python good rocks to work with such
type of data and analyze their results
so then we have some specific lessons
transcriptomics in r or transcriptomics
in Python that will help you and that
will help you build this understanding
of how you can use the r code blog or
the python code block to work with your
data to analyze data and interpret the
results that you get so this was about
how different types of course materials
can you find here on the portal now
again you can't directly jump into
transcriptomics in r or python if you
know nothing about RN python you would
definitely uh want to have a basic setup
or know something about how to get
started with our our python as a
language so we have some resources for
you here that you can leverage so you
will find courses on RN python as well
where you will learn from basics
how to specifically set up your art
studio and then load data and read DNA
sequences so this is a very basic
coursework which will help you get
started with this language and also
introduce you to various libraries and
packages and then the second coursework
that was coming up will take you from an
intermediate to an advanced level where
you'll also learn about statistical
analysis and the various data
visualization methods so this was a very
brief overview of what courses have we
put together all right now in your
training you are required to complete a
specific set of coursework based on your
interest and once you have completed
this coursework the question arises how
do I apply the knowledge that I gained
from a specific coursework to answer a
research question
so for that we have some example
projects put together so let's say I
have now completed transcriptomics
training and I want to now uh see how I
could run the transcriptomics pipeline
to work with uh data from liver cancer
patients all right so this is there we
have put together some example projects
for uh our research fellows and also for
Learners who would like to learn you can
go through these example projects to
actually learn how research questions
could be answered uh with the specific
type of training that you will complete
through these courseworks and they are
really good case studies which will help
you build some good uh background to get
started with your research so that was
about courses and example projects now
as I mentioned that when you get started
with your with the coursework it's
important that you have a research
interest and many a times when I meet a
research fellows in their orientation
sessions so when uh where a student
joins the research fellowship program we
basically conduct an orientation session
where we want to understand what is the
interest the research fellow wants to
work on and what are they seeking why
are they working on a project actually
is it for their dissertation to Summit
in their college as a requirement to
complete their degree or they are doing
this to get a publication to get
accepted into a PhD program or uh they
are or if they are if they are a working
professional and just working on a
project to upscale their skill set and
in that orientation session I genuinely
need students from
graduation and post graduation who are
confused that what should be their
research interest what they should be
begin with and they don't they are
interested in it's not streamlined that
is what I can say